we here in the west have got a very
serious challenge a challenge that we've
only waken up to very recently you're
the former prime minister of a western
country in Asia and the one thing I
think people in in the west are really
not appreciating is the seriousness of
the moment that we're in China has
engaged in the biggest peacetime
rearmament in history over the last
decade people who come here illegally by
boat the gummed up system I can't
believe the contortions that stop the
creation of an effective policy
here Tony abber it's a great pleasure to
have you on the show we want to talk to
you about China immigration and a bunch
of other things but the thing that we
really felt is so important to raise
with you you're the former prime
minister of a Western Country in asah MH
um and the one thing I think people in
in the west are really not appreciating
is the seriousness of the moment that
we're in when the president of Russia
the leader of China the leader of Iran
are all talking about the multi-polar
world people don't seem to appreciate
what's going on and I know that you have
some unique thoughts on that that I
really wanted you to share with people
well Constantin I think you're right uh
we've had 70 years of unparalleled and
unprecedented peace and prosperity if
you take the world in 2020 just before
the pandemic
never before had people all around the
globe been more free uh more Rich uh
more safe and since then we had a
pandemic where frankly policy to deal
with it did far more damage than the
disease itself uh in the process we
settled ourselves with mountainous debt
uh in the process we sapped our work
ethic and uh damaged our Spirits um
and then of course uh we had the Ukraine
war which was a horrific reminder uh
that war between Nation States was not a
thing of the past uh that aggression by
large countries against small ones was
not a thing of the past while the
initial Western response to the horrific
Russian invasion was pretty good the
truth is that we've given the ukrainians
enough Military Support for to avoid
being defeated but we haven't given them
enough to allow them to drive every last
Russian soldier from every last inch of
Ukrainian territory which frankly is the
only fair outcome here uh and now we've
got this horrific business in the Middle
East where Hamas have Unleashed on the
innocent people of Israel an attack of
the most appalling
savagery and right around the world
including in cities like London and my
own hometown of Sydney you've got large
sways of the population who seem to be
on the side of the terrorists rather
than the people who are trying to Stamp
Out terrorism we had the most appalling
scenes in Sydney uh just a night or two
after the initial Massacre where
hundreds and hundreds of demonstrators
were crying out literally um gas the
Jews F the Jew
now in Australia as in Britain we have a
vast anti-racism
apparatus and this vast anti-racism
apparatus has not as yet raised a finger
against those people who are preaching
the most unspeakable race hate on our
streets so we here in the west have got
uh a very serious challenge a challenge
that we've only waken up to very
recently from dictators on the
March we've probably got an even bigger
Challenge and that is to believe in
ourselves believe in our values because
so many people who should know better do
not seem to appreciate that for all the
faults of countries like Australia
countries like Britain countries like
the United States these are the best
societies uh that mankind has ever had
and until recently these were the best
times that mankind has ever had and our
challenge is to try to ensure that we
have not already lived through the best
of times and so so much to pick up on
there and I wanted to talk about
geopolitics and all the other stuff but
there was something you touched on and I
know to many people it seems like old
news but I will say this to hear a
former prime minister of a major Western
Country talk about our response to Co in
the way that you just did it is so
comforting actually I mean what was
happening including in your country was
horrific extraordinary extraordinary and
it was particularly dispiriting that so
much of this happened under governments
of the center right because at the heart
of the center right political philosophy
is a greater freedom and smaller
government and yet here we
had uh the Boris Johnson government in
Britain uh imposing absolutely
unprecedented restrictions on freedom um
uh creating absolutely massively
intrusive systems of
surveillance um it was more the states
that did it in Australia than the feds
itself but the feds certainly acquiesced
uh in all of this and one of the reasons
why people on the political center right
I think have been so discombobulated and
somewhat dispirited lately uh is because
the people who are supposed to be our
leaders have acted so against those
things that are supposed to be our
instincts and the other extraordinary
thing is that no one seems interested in
having a serious hard-headed
look at exactly how we we overreacted so
badly exactly how the pandemic plans
that had been carefully prepared over
decades were junked in panic in the
first week of March when the Italian
hospital system appeared to be
collapsing and instead of the
sensible um modulated proportionate
plans that had long been prepared basic
basically everyone except for Sweden and
except for some states in the United
States everyone adopted a varant of the
Wuhan plan which was to lock everyone up
close everything down hope that you
could somehow uninvent this virus and it
was always simply wrong and at no point
were the obvious things that we do in
almost every other instance uh applied
that's to say cost benefit analysis
which ask well what is the danger we are
attempting to deal with what are the
costs of trying to deal with it and how
do we balance this out at no point was
any of that done instead in a in an
extraordinary moral and physical Panic
uh governments did things which the
consequence the the the the the the
doleful consequences of which we will be
living with for years to come and you
you made it quite a profound point there
time where you were talking about we're
not sensible or rational in our response
to co I don't think we're sensible or
rational in our response to anything at
the moment if I'm being brutally honest
you can take any particular topic or
issue and you look at the way it's been
covered and the way people talk about it
a lot of the times it's fundamentally
irrational isn't
it look uh there are any number of other
issues that we can talk about we could
talk about the the climate cult we could
talk about the gender fluidity push uh
we could talk about the magic pting
economics we could talk most profoundly
about the cultural self-loathing which
appears to afflict the best countries on
Earth um crazy things are happening
everywhere uh in fact I one of the books
that I would like to write and of
tentatively begun I've given the working
title to Peak Insanity because I I think
that is something that we are um on the
verge of in these it's quite an
optimistic title because you're assuming
we're not going to keep going well well
well eventually as Margaret Thatcher
once observed the facts are conservative
uh eventually um the emissions obsession
will run up against the need for us to
have affordable reliable power uh
eventually the cultural self-loathing
will run up against a military challenge
from a dictatorship and and when those
things happen um sanity will return the
sad thing is that things might have to
get somewhat worse before they start to
get very much better so you're saying
that we've still got a little bit of
Road in the whole Insanity to go one of
the one of the uh encouraging straws in
the wind was the recent decision by the
sonak government uh to wind back some of
Britain's uh crazy policies on electric
cars and uh and and and banning gas
boilers uh because plainly they were
going to impose massive costs and
disruptions on decent Ordinary
aspirational People for no environmental
gain I mean even if you accept uh the
anthropogenic global warming thesis that
somehow Mankind's carbon dioxide
emissions are a grave threat to the
planet even if you accept that thesis
and I think it's highly contentious but
even if you accept that thesis the idea
that Britain could somehow save the
world on its own by inflicting massive
cost punishments on its people was just
well it was kind of uh uh political pyom
masochism on a grand scale uh it was
economic and social self harm on a grand
scale now there's still lots of other
uh uh Folly out
there I mean genuinely achieving Net
Zero within the next 30 Years with the
next 25 years almost um is going to
devastate our economies just at a time
uh when our strategic challenges
particularly China are doing no such
thing so they're spending tens and tens
of billions of dollars trillions of
dollars on on armaments and we're
spending uh billions and ultimately
trillions of dollars to convert uh a
perfectly reasonable coal gas oil and
nuclear-based power system to something
based on windmills solar panels and
batteries well I I mean it's completely
irrational but it's driven by uh
apocalyptic fears uh of climate
Extinction uh based on shudo science and
a complete ignorance of History Tony
we're sitting here in Westminster right
in the heart of of the capital if you of
the and the British political system
actually if you were to go out there and
say what you just said about you know
the climate cult you're very skeptical
of the anthropogenic climate change
thesis all of that most most people
haven't heard that and to hear a former
prime minister of Australia say that I
think would be quite uh shocking to them
why do you say those it's one of the
reasons why I got turfed out uh because
too many people inside my own party uh
thought that I was too Hardline on some
of these issues they thought that uh um
that was a uh a sort of a robust
conservatism that they doubted uh its
electoral salability if you like and yet
the interesting thing about Australia is
that every election we've had where
climate change has been an issue um and
where the conservative side of politics
has said look we are not going to
sacrifice people's economic well-being
to reduce
emissions the conservative side is one
uh in
2010 climate change was an issue and
uh we took a first-term government when
I was the leader of the opposition to
minority status uh in 2013 when the
labor government's carbon tax was one of
the key issues we had a thumping win in
2016 in Australia Malcolm turull who was
then prime minister didn't campaign on
climate because essentially he and the
labor party agreed uh we almost lost in
2019 Scott Morrison as prime minister
did campaign uh on climate saying that
Labor's then 45% emissions reduction
Target uh would be um very economically
damaging cost us something like a half a
trillion dollars um and then in 2022
after the Morrison government committed
to Net Zero as part of um the whole
Glasgow uh gabfest um we didn't campaign
on climate and we lost and lost badly in
part because the people who were looking
to us
to defend their economic interests
against these kind of first world
obsessions if you like thought that we'd
badly let them down and lost our spine
but Tony I'm not a I'm not a political
expert but it's not shocking to me that
people don't want to be made poor for
for these ideas but I was curious to
hear why you're skeptical Constantin
they they need they need leadership and
one of the difficulties at the
moment is
that uh I mean people say that the whole
uh if you like political Spectrum has
shifted to the left in recent years I'm
not so sure about that and if it has
it's because the so-called right has not
had very much courage and conviction I
mean look at the conservative
governments here in Britain over the
last decade or so David Cameron uh an
outstanding
individual uh a person I I admire and
like um I think his difficulty was in
part that he was in Coalition with the
lib
Dems uh but but on
climate it it was a government that very
much had drunk the Kool-Aid so to speak
um it was Tera May who pushed through
Parliament this declaration that we were
facing a a climate
emergency um Boris
Johnson
um a wonderfully capable man uh a a
brilliant wizard of a politician at his
best um who should forever be remembered
uh as the man who got brexit done
nevertheless turned out to be an
absolute climate Zealot as prime
minister perhaps the worst of climate
zealotry as prime minister even though
uh in the days when he was writing about
these things he was always uh a
considerable
skeptic now thank God Rishi sonak seems
to be bringing some kind of moderation
and proportionality to all of this and
and yet plainly there is a group of
people inside the conservative party uh
who are proving difficult on this maybe
because they really have uh succumbed to
this view that we're all doomed unless
we radically and swiftly reduce
emissions maybe they think that the
public have succumbed to The View and
their job is not to lead but to follow
uh or maybe they just want to be
difficult for whoever the prime minister
of the time is but nevertheless uh while
I think Rishi sonak um gave himself an
enormous boost
and started to create at least a glimmer
of Hope of Victory at the next election
with that recent move there's a lot more
that really should be done and this is
why I keep questioning you because we
still haven't got to the to the answer
which is if we are to persuade people we
have to give them a persuasive argument
because people who who are told that you
know the Earth is about to burn will
will be persuaded to support policies
that amarate that so so what is the
argument that you know you're making
because some people might say well
you've just listed a bunch of
conservative Prime Ministers here who
disagree very strongly with your view so
why are you skeptical about the climate
narrative okay well I I
accept uh the physics that all other
things being equal uh an increase in
atmospheric carbon dioxide should warm
the planet I accept that but climate is
an incredibly complex mechanism an
incredibly complex
mechanism
and the biggest impact uh on climate uh
is the sun uh if we have more sunspot
activity the world warms if we have less
sunspot activity the world cools the
next biggest impact on climate is
oscillations in the Earth's orbit if we
get a little bit closer to the Sun it
gets hotter if we get a little bit
further away from the Sun uh it gets
cooler now we know the climate has
changed dramatically over time um back
in the days of the Dinosaurs the world
was much much warmer than it is today um
back in the days of the ice ages the
world was much cooler than it is today
Mankind's carbon dioxide had nothing to
do with any of those periods of intense
climate change so there are many many
many other factors I mean you cannot
deny that there are many many other
factors in climate apart from Simply
carbon dioxide and even on carbon
dioxide um man's contribution to the
annual production of carbon dioxide is
relatively
small um the Roman warm period somewhat
hotter than today the medieval warm
period uh somewhat hotter than today the
mini ice age in the 1600s when the Tams
would freeze over somewhat colder than
today so but
again human carbon dioxide emissions had
nothing to do with that so there's
absolutely no doubt that climate does
change yes um increases in atmospheric
carbon di oxide all things being equal
will tend to warm the planet but this
idea that going from roughly 300 parts
per million of carbon dioxide 100 years
ago to 400 parts per million of carbon
dioxide today and depending upon what
happens perhaps 500 parts of carbon
dioxide in 50 or 100 uh years time it's
very hard to believe that this is quite
the Catalyst for catastrophic change
that the alarmists make out and even if
it is going to bring about serious
change such as two or three degrees of
extra warming such as um two to 5 meters
of sea level rise these are things that
we can adapt to over time and the
important thing is to be as rich and as
strong as we can be when facing these
challenges not to impoverish ourselves
um to meet an enemy which may not be uh
nearly as serious as as we think now I
know they talk about the you know the uh
the precautionary principle um and and
that's true uh we should take reasonable
precautions uh against uh plausible
threats that's why we have a military
force and a nuclear deterrent things
like that but honestly uh would a couple
of degrees of warming be the catastrophe
that the alarmists make it out to be I
mean ask yourself that question um if
you could wear a t-shirt more often in
London would that be a disaster um if it
was possible uh to swim a bit longer in
Cornwall uh would that be a disaster now
sure uh it might be a problem for ski
field
um but is this really the absolute
catastrophe uh against which so much of
our economy and Society has to be
transformed that the alarmist make it
out to be I don't believe it is now when
I was prime minister I took the view
that climate does
change uh mankind does make a difference
uh we should take reasonable steps to
reduce our emissions as far and as fast
as possible but and this was the
critical Proviso not at the expense of
jobs uh of
Industries
and badly damaging ordinary people's
cost of
living we'll get back to the episode in
a minute but first we want to talk to
you about ag1 if you're a longtime fan
you might know we've been drinking ag1
for over a year now to stay healthy and
saave off illness in preparation for
whenever our schedule gets really busy
when we use ag1 on our busy America
tours we found that we feel a real
difference to our energy levels and our
ability to focus so my concentration
span has gone from 2 seconds to 12
that's because ag1 is a foundational
nutrition supplement that supports your
body's Universal needs like gut
optimization Stress Management and
immune support since 2010 ag1 has led
the future of foundational nutrition
continuously refining their formula to
create a smarter better way to elevate
your Baseline Health even the
trigonometry team here have started
drinking ag1 and they love it our
producer was just telling me about how
much more energetic he feels that his
stress levels feel more manageable now
and because of this we're hoping he'll
hit his deadlines for the first time in
over 5 years ag1 is the supplement I
trust to support my daily health and
that's why they've been a trigonometry
partner for so long now if you want to
take ownership of your health it starts
with ag1 try ag1 and get a free one-year
supply of vitamin D3 K2 and five free
ag1 travel packs with your first
purchase go to drink a1.com
trigonometry that's drink a1.com
trigonometry check it out and now back
to the
interview and that is such an important
point because the thing that I get
frustrated with Tony is when we're
talking about this and people going you
know we need to do X Y and Z and you go
we in a cost a living crisis here mate
people can barely afford to buy food
what you're now going to jack up their
energy prices by three times or whatever
it is it's it's not sustainable and and
this is where ordinary
people uh are starting to
think the risk in even in great and
stable democra acies like our own the
risk is that ordinary people will lose
faith in the system because they will
see the people who they elect to do the
right thing and the political parties
who they thought they could trust to be
sensible and reasonable uh pursuing
these things that just look to be
contrary to Common Sense and when that
happens and we've already seen this in
in Continental Europe when that happens
you get um Fringe parties arise uh which
often uh you can understand you can
understand people looking for
Alternatives but unfortunately the
Alternatives um sometimes get a bit
kooky and and that's to be avoided as
well so look um the these are these are
difficult times and the countries which
have
been beacons of Hope to the world for so
many centuries now uh need to look to
themselves lest we
let each other down and lest we fail to
give the guidance to the rest of the
globe that we have for so long I would
actually argue Tony that in some ways
it's better that you get these kooky
parties spring up because at least that
shows a faith in democracy rather than
what happen is actually happening in our
country where people go the system's
broken it's not working I'm stepping
back from the system no but but but you
know when I got turfed as prime minister
I had literally thousands of letters and
emails many of which said start a new
political party and I always responded I
said look I can understand your feeling
but frankly it's better to repair an
existing party than it is to try to
start a new one and this is where I say
to people if you don't like the way
things are going don't despair don't opt
out don't rush off uh to start U you
know the true conservative party or you
know the make Britain Great again party
or something like that join the existing
political party which best suits your
instincts and make it better than it is
because you know now 100 people inside a
political party can do far more than a
thousand people outside a political
party you always affect change better
from the inside than the outside and
whatever faults our major political
parties have in countries like Britain
Australia and America they are still
open to the influence of their members
um maybe they're manipulated from the
top by actions uh maybe there are
various stitch-ups done from time to
time to deny the membership a fair say
but you have still got far more
influence as a member of a political
party than as someone just demonstrating
on the street okay so I put a
counterargument to you what about we're
sitting in Westminster there is nobody
who has changed Westminster more in the
last 10 to 15 years in Nigel farage and
I accept that I accept that Nigel farage
has been um uh uh quite a seismic Force
but for Nigel farage brexit would never
have happened but and and this is where
Britain has been lucky the conservatives
been been lucky and Nigel has shown
considerable
character uh back in
2019 uh had he run brexit party
candidates in every seat he probably
would have stopped the Johnson
government from winning a majority but
instead quite cleverly having got at
last a conservative leader who was faed
income about getting brexit done he then
ran uh candidates tactically if you like
to ensure that he did not get in the way
of a conservative Victory now now now
you you
say shouldn't democracy give us a new
political party well the trouble is
democracy will often give us uh complete
chaos depending upon how the system
works before it gives us a new
equilibrium and while I don't say that
there can never be a case for a new
political party in this country the
conservative party has something like
300 years of History um
it's invented and reinvented itself many
times over that period but
always at the heart of the conservative
instinct is a respect for
tradition um
awareness about change where there are
not clear and obvious benefits and an
intense
patriotism uh because as I say at the
heart of all decent center right
political movements there's Freedom
there's
tradition and there's p
patriotism love of country is very much
at the heart of all
respectable conservative political
parties and certainly it's always been
at the heart uh of the British
conservative party and I guess the
classic exampl have been Winston
Churchill and Margaret Thatcher Tony I
would add another U another item to that
list which is prudence and financial
responsibility and this is one thing
that uh I mean Australia is actually a
country that has historically been much
more prudent sensible running surpluses
not hasn't had recessions at times other
Western countries have but I I want to
get your perspective on this because it
seems to me that Britain in America in
particular have have have abandoned any
pretense of fiscal responsibility we
print so much money now and the concern
that I have and I'm very curious to hear
your thoughts as a former prime minister
is that I don't understand how that ever
gets dealt with because we have this
narrative now whenever we try to reduce
spending uh that you know you're killing
people the moment you tried to cut any
spending and so I just don't see how
that ever gets address how are we going
to get out of this incred we we our debt
is bigger than our our
GDP the most successful Australian
government in recent times was the
Howard
government and there were a couple of
key factors in its
success uh the most obvious key factor
in its success was that John Howard
was essentially unchallenged as a leader
throughout his 11 years at the top and
he had around him um a nucleus of very
capable people uh of of strong and good
character
Peter Costello who might have challenged
John Howard and turned the Howard
government into a much shorter term
government than it was um while he at
times got frustrated with John's
longevity uh in the end he accepted that
he had a duty um to be a team player as
opposed to a one of those me me me
politicians so that was one factor the
other factor which is insufficiently
credited is that back in
1991 uh under the leadership of John
Houston the liberal National Coalition
went through a very
extensive effectively a first principles
review of policy and we ultimately
produced something called
fightback uh which amongst other things
recommended the introduction of a goods
and services tax but it was so much more
than just that um it was really a
reconsideration of government from the
ground up what was government doing
wrong uh that had to be made right uh
what was government doing that it
shouldn't do at all uh and what um
wasn't being done by government which
should be done by government and and
that fightback package effectively
provided a blueprint
that guided the thinking of the Howard
government throughout its nearly 12
years in office now John Houston was an
insufficiently skilled political
salesman up against in Paul keing a
political hunter killer of of of of
great of great skill at the 1993
election to win but nevertheless that
fightback policy document was an
incredibly important piece of work which
was very much responsible for the Howard
government's ultimate success now what
we need now uh in Australia in Britain
and in the United States basically each
of our countries uh needs serious
credible people to sit down and work out
a new plan and it can't just be the
economic rationalism uh of the Reagan
Thatcher era important though it is
there's got to be a focus on society as
well as just on the economy but we've
got to think of how do we make our
economies more Dynamic more productive
um how do we beat Russia and China in
the technology race that's important to
keeping ourselves safe um while at the
same time preserving the social fabric
uh so there's an economic challenge
there's a social challenge now at the
moment we are spending gargant amounts
of money uh industrializing effectively
uh aged care disability care and child
care I'm not saying this is easy but we
need to find ways of spending Less on
commercializing and corporatizing these
things which in a better world would be
done by the family because that too uh
is part of building a better society and
respecting the social Fabric and then we
need to have a long hard think about our
defenses now the military force forces
even of the United States have been
massively wound down over the last 30
years and as we are now seeing while we
have been winding things down our
strategic competitors have been
massively winding things up China has
engaged in the biggest peacetime
rearmament in history uh over the last
decade and that's why we don't just have
this Dreadful problem uh in Eastern
Europe we don't just have um
a potential Apocalypse in the Middle
East but we've also got the Peril of of
of of a conflict uh in East Asia which
would have
ramifications far far exceeding it would
be many orders of magnitude more
disruptive than the Ukraine conf we
we'll come to China and sa let me just
finish on the economy and then you do
China you you say we need to spend less
on this on what we call social care and
all of this other stuff right uh and if
if it was done by the family that would
be we need to spend smarter yeah I
understand and and over time if we spend
smarter we should spend less and it
should be done by the family which
brings me to the problem that we have
and which I think is driving a lot of
the wokeness that we all complain about
which is how how do you have families
looking after elderly people or their
own children when the cost of housing is
so high that both parents have to work
just to make ends me and here in London
even two very successful professional
people struggle to get on the housing
ladder let or you even afford rent so
that there is a trap and I'm curious how
you would resolve
that well it's a complex problem there's
no doubt about that and while there are
lots of things that you can do that will
help uh there's no magic wand here what
are the things that are feeding into the
housing crisis um
partly it's the cost of construction uh
which is
um often being driven by at times
unreasonable environmental and planning
rules uh partly
it's the quantitative easing of the last
decade which has resulted in massive
asset price inflation
uh and partly it's immigration now um in
Australia
uh there was uh net overseas migration
averaging about 100,000 a year in the
Howard era since then it's averaged
close to 300,000 a year and just at the
moment we're expecting about
800,000 um longterm arrivals uh over the
current 2-year period and that's putting
downward pressure on wages upward
pressure on housing massive pressure on
infrastructure of all types whether it's
public transport roads schools hospitals
Etc uh and yet one of the difficulties
that we've got is that it's
pervasive um amongst the commanding
Heights of contemporary anglosphere
societies that immigration is an
unalloyed economic good and that
immigration is actually a moral
obligation upon us we have no right to
say to people who turn up in a rubber
ducky on the beaches near DOA uh or the
people who come in a fishing boat from
java to Australia we have no right to
say no to youh um I mean I cannot
believe
um the the the moral contortions which
stop Britain uh from uh getting itself
from out of this European legal
entanglement uh which prevents um
Britain doing what we did in Australia
with Naru and PNG sending people to
aanda uh I cannot believe um the gummed
up system which means that people who
come here illegally by boat and who
plainly are not fed inome refugees I
mean they've gone through many safe
countries before they get on a boat in
France to come to Britain so they're not
fed inome refugees at all I mean sure
they might ultimately have come from
nasty horrible countries but if they
were fed inome refugees they would seek
sanctuary in the first safe country to
which they'd come and that might have
been turkey uh it might have been in
Italy it certainly is in Britain um I
can't believe the contortions that
stop um the creation of an effective
policy here um but again it's it's the
it's it's the moral uncertainty it's the
cultural self-doubt which has Afflicted
the Western leadership to a greater or
lesser extent for some decades now
certainly since the Reagan
Thatcher Pope John Paul era there's
been uh a grave weakening of the moral
Clarity with which the leaders of the
western world have operated but Tony
this goes back to what you said so you
said you know that you got pushed out
ostensibly because you were pretty hard
lying about certain issues well it was
one of the factors I I also had someone
who didn't stay in the parliament to be
someone else's Minister and fair enough
you're entitled to be ambitious and I
suppose if you see an opportunity to
seize the numbers and make yourself the
PM go for it the the the problem was
that a government that was elected to be
a government of the C the center right
uh to be if you like a government very
much in the mold of John Howard um
turned out not to be that after I was
after I left office and and I think that
was not only bad for the liberal
National Coalition in Australia uh but I
don't think it was great for the quality
of government either but that's the
problem let's look at it in a broader
sense Tony that's pretty much what is
happening when people see every
government in the Western World this is
a government that purports to be one
thing it turns out to be another the
conservatives aren't conservatives labor
aren't particularly leftwing the liberal
Democrats you wait you wait till they
get Eng they will be very very leftwing
indeed I mean a better way of saying it
would have been labor AR Pro labor
they're Pro all of
this they're no longer a working class
party Class party that's what he me
that's what but that's what I mean by
left wing they're not traditional
leftwing okay you've got the liberal
Democrats who after brexit or during
brexit proved themselves to be neither
liberal nor Democratic so this is really
what we're talking about here which is a
crisis but again again in a democracy
ultimately the people get the government
they deserve so if you think that the
political parties that you normally vote
for are failing you you can complain and
and belly ache uh you can opt out
or you can get involved and make a
difference and my hope is that more
people will get involved and make a
difference because in the end the
quality of our democracy does not just
depend upon our leaders it depends upon
each one of
us do you have a website or do you plan
to have a website because if you do then
easy DNS is a company for you easy DNS
is the perfect domain name registar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be cancel culture
deplatform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows about that
so we'll you in a second easy DNS have
Rock Solid net Network infrastructure
and fantastic customer support they're
in your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your ex
girlfriend in which case you're on your
own you know about that move your
domains and websites over to easy DNS
right now all you've got to do is go to
easy
dns.com triggered that's easy
dns.com SLT triggered use our promo code
which is also triggered and get 50% off
the initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy which tells
you everything you need to know about
technology privacy and
censorship and this is very much the
reason why we started this show because
we saw that something was a and we
wanted to talk about it and we could see
that nobody or very few people in the
mainstream media were actually being
honest about it but let's actually look
at China because that is something that
worries me I don't think it's something
we discuss about enough and people see
the issue of Taiwan and you know put
their fingers in their ears and go
pretty much la la la but if you look at
what's happened in Ukraine if you look
about the horrendous attack on Israel it
seems logical that Taiwan is
next well there's no doubt in my mind
that the commissars in Beijing uh have
been closely watching all of this and
they will be carefully weighing uh their
chances of getting away with an assault
on Taiwan because just as Putin sees
himself as having if you like a mission
from God to recreate greater Russia xiin
ping and his colleagues see themselves
as having uh a mission from whatever God
they worship uh to end the century of
humiliation um and to make China once
more the world's Middle Kingdom the
global
dominant power now the first step uh was
to modernize their economy MH they've
substantially done that the next step
was to crush Hong Kong they've
substantially done
that now the step is to seize Taiwan
even though Taiwan is a practically
independent liberal democracy of 25
million people which after considering
what China has done to the commitments
it made in respect of Hong Kong is never
going to agree is never going to agree
to submit to rule from
Beijing uh and the only thing that will
stop uh Beijing from at some point in
time attempting to seize Taiwan by force
is the knowledge that it won't just be
1.4 billion Chinese against 25 million
Taiwanese it will effectively be China
against an array of powerful democracies
and this is why whatever um quibbles we
might have with with Joe Biden four
times now he said that if China did
attack Taiwan America would defend
Taiwan um the policy of strategic
ambiguity has not been formal abandoned
but I think it has been um certainly
amended by Biden um but it's one thing
to say that America will defend Taiwan
it's another thing uh for America to be
readily able to do so particularly if a
lot of their ordinance stocks have been
sent to Ukraine and particularly if a
lot of their military assets are in the
Eastern Mediterranean to try to sure
that Iran doesn't start playing horrific
games uh with Israel and and this is
where I'm afraid uh we have all reveled
in the peace dividend over the last 30
years forgetting that human nature
hasn't changed uh that geopolitics
hasn't gone away and that in the
end if you want to be free
you've got to be prepared to defend your
freedom and if you want the world to be
just you've got to be prepared to stand
up against Injustice now hopefully
hopefully um armed conflict can be
avoided U because as we are seeing in
Ukraine and as we've now seen um in in
in Israel and in Gaza um the cost is
horrific and yet yet the one thing that
invites armed conflict is weakness
absolutely and there's been too much
weakness for too long absolutely we've
been signaling weakness sorry it yeah
and so what would you do Tony because
you're the only one in this room who is
Led a nation what would you do if you
were in charge of the United
States well I would stop weakening uh my
economy with all these unne Neary green
regulations um I
would accept that at least for the
foreseeable future um in the absence of
going to nuclear power or the as yet uh
entirely unfeasible green hydrogen dream
uh we are going to have to continue to
make use of coal and gas so so I would
stop imposing a whole lot of unnecessary
hobbles on my
economy uh I would stop dividing and
disconcerting my Society um
through woke
education um through um all sorts of
concessions to uh the gender fluidity uh
ideology and so on and I would build up
my defenses uh I mean the American
Military uh is smaller than it should be
um the stocks of of Munitions are lower
than they should
be um their capacity to build chips and
planes is less than it should be and
this is all equally true in Britain and
and it
is
it's
incredibly uh regrettable
that for too long all of us have been
sleepwalking through Lotus land I mean I
can remember saying to one of my
distinguished British conservative
counterparts some years ago um on this
question of Britain
spending 7% of GDP on overseas aid at
the same time when it was cutting the
military I remember saying to as I said
a distinguished counterpart the
conservative government surely the best
form of foreign aid is the British army
I mean why the hell are you cutting
defense and at the same time boosting
foreign aid much of which will be wasted
much of which will end up in the pockets
of corrupt uh governments in Africa in
particular when you know that if the
world is in trouble having uh a military
force that can be deployed to restore
order and where needs be in still a bit
of respect uh in dictators and other
malactor
that's what you really want Tony do you
think we've fundamentally lost what
you've just said I've not heard a
politician say this you know when you
said you know let's make dictators aware
that we're not messing around here like
I don't hear politicians talk like that
anymore and I think we invite all of
these challenges to to us in this way
and and and Constantin um how has Israel
survived for so long uh in a
hostile part of the world I mean how
have less than 10 million
Israelis not just survived but
flourished and created a highly
prosperous uh free and fair Society
despite all of the threats the
existential threats that theyve faced in
the midst
of the turmoil uh of of the Middle
East they've they've done so because
there have never been any any doubt
about the national project which is to
create an absolutely secure and
inviable Homeland for the Jewish people
where
others who are prepared to accept the
law can also have a very good life and a
free life but but at the heart of
Israel's success and survival has been
this uh notion that if someone does
something bad to us uh we don't just
take it on the chin um we give it back
to them uh you punch me I punch you back
you punch me again I punch you back much
harder uh you punch me three times uh
and frankly uh I knock you out I mean
this has been their their approach
and I mean this is where there is a
fundamental difference between
the necessities of government and if you
like the desiderat of moral theology yes
one of the reasons why moral theologians
don't normally make a good Statesmen is
because the good Lord commands us to
love uh but the reality of government is
that we have got to be just uh and
Justice and charity are not the same
thing um if private citizens want to
exercise charity that's a wonderful
thing uh and God bless them for that uh
but the obligation on government is to
be just and the ultimate just government
uh is a government which quite properly
and fiercely protects its citizens
against all their enemies Tony I'm going
to ask you a question which again it's
on the China thing it may seem to be
quite unfair but I I really think I'm
because I'm actually really worried
about this do you think that this is
almost
inevitable that they're going to invade
because if you look at the way things
are going if you look it seems to me log
it's the next logical step isn't
it now it's not inevitable for instance
the rulers of the rulers of
Beijing
uh they're not a death cult they're not
like Hamas uh they are cruel and they
are
focused uh but they're not crazy
and they will do a calculus uh and if
they think that the cost of aggression
Across The Straits uh is too high then
in the end it will bring them undone
they won't do it um if they think they
can readily win well then at some point
they will and that's why
the important thing is to make crystal
clear to the commissar in Beijing that
any assault across the streets will have
incalc calculable
consequences and you say they're not a
death cult which is is obviously very
reassuring but I think the problem is
and there something we talk about on
this show a lot is that when we talk
about other cultures we think they're
like us they see the world the same way
corre when different cultures have
different ways of living they have
different values yes correct correct um
and and again um you you look at U Hamas
and you look at Islamic State that was
um they are essentially a death
cult they think that if they can kill in
the name of their version of Islam um
that's the highest purpose in life uh
Putin's not quite like that and nor are
the commissar in Beijing uh what they're
looking at is uh National agism
effectively uh
so they're cruel um they're
brutal sometimes they do evil things as
Putin is now doing in
Ukraine but they're not irrational it's
just that their rationality is is very
different from ours uh a British
government thinks how can I get
reelected by making the lives of the
British people better how can I run
better hospitals how can I build more
roads how can I increase Prosperity
that's what a British government is
mostly thinking about uh but Putin is
mostly thinking about how do I restore
the Russia of Peter the Great uh and
xiin ping is mostly thinking about how
do I make China as soon as possible the
world's number one power
now their way of thinking is different
from ours and we need to understand that
and we need to tailor our responses to
them in the light of what they are like
rather than assuming that they're just
like us and this has been the problem
ever since the fall of the Berlin wall
and the so-called end of history and the
so-called forever Triumph of uh liberal
market capitalism uh we have assumed
that there is this convergence
um we were if I may say may say so
fooling ourselves and look um to some
extent uh I was part of that self-
delusion I mean I did a free trade deal
with China back in 2014 uh because back
then it was still possible to believe
that China's economic liberalization was
being accompanied by a degree of
political liberalization and over time
uh that would produce a markedly
different and much less aggressive China
so look uh we were all guled a bit we
all wanted to believe the best not the
worst we've had one hell of a wakeup
call and though the hour is late we need
to be stronger
better and more realistic in the coming
years than we've been in the recent past
T it's been a pleasure we've got a few
minutes which we'll spend with our
supporters on locals with you answering
their questions before we head over
there uh what is the one thing that
we're not talking about that you think
we really should be well the one thing
that I'd probably like to
say uh to a British audience in
particular is believe in yourselves
believe in yourselves um I've always
been an encourageable
angile uh because was no country on
Earth
has had more impact on the modern world
than this one when you think of the
world's common language uh the mother of
parliaments the Industrial Revolution
the emancipation of minorities all of
that began here and spread from here uh
to just about the whole of the globe
even our adversaries have been very much
influenced and shaped uh by the ideas
and the innovations that that have come
from this country and yet for the last
Almost the last century uh at The
Pinacle of the British establishment
there's been this declinism and
defeatism get it out of your heads
please believe in yourselves because if
we want the modern world to flourish
it's important that Britain be as strong
and as self-confident as possible amen
all right guys head on over to locals
where where we're going to put your
questions to Tony
Abbott we fixed this problem in fact we
are the only country to successfully in
recent times halt u a large wave of
illegal immigration by small boat first
of all we established a unified
[Music]
ch